nos dicen esta tabla define la función f
muy bien para cada valor de x nos dan un
valor correspondiente de fx de acuerdo a
la tabla efe es par impar o ninguna
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
por su cuenta muy bien vamos a
resolverlo juntos vamos a recordar la
definición de par e impar una definición
que podemos repasar es que si fx es
igual a efe de menos x
entonces tenemos una función par y si fx
es igual a menos
efe de menos x u otra forma de decir
esto es que si efe - x es igual a menos
fx estas dos son equivalentes en estas
dos situaciones tenemos una función
impar y sin ninguno de estos se cumple
entonces tenemos ninguna que es lo que
sucede aquí veamos
efe de menos 7 es igual a menos 1 que
hay del negativo de f de menos 7 eso
sería efe de 7 y vemos que f de 7
también es igual a menos 1 así que al
menos
acaso si pensamos en x 7 f x es igual a
efe x así que funciona para esto también
funciona para 3 y para menos 3
efe de 3 es igual a menos f de menos 3
ambos son iguales a 2 y podemos
visualizar mentalmente esta asimetría en
el eje y por lo que esta parece una
función par elegimos esta opción hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí nuevamente la tabla
define la función f y tenemos una
función f diferente esta función es par
impar o ninguna pausa en el vídeo y
traten de pensar en esto muy bien veamos
algunos ejemplos
aquí tenemos 5 que es igual a 2 a que es
igual
efe de menos 5 no sólo no es igual a 2
tendría que ser igual a 2 para que sea
una función par y tendría que ser igual
a menos 2 para que fuera una función
impar pero no coincide con alguna así
que podemos ver claramente con este
punto que no es para mí
por lo que la opción es ninguna hagamos
un ejemplo más de nuevo la tabla define
la función f de acuerdo a la tabla efe
es par impar o ninguna pausa en de nuevo
el vídeo y traten de responder a esto
vamos a comenzar por acá tenemos
efe de 4 igual a menos 8 a que es igual
efe de menos 4 la idea aquí es ver que
si f dx es igual a algo a que se da
igual efe
x aquí nos dan efe de menos 4 y es igual
a 8 por lo que parece que no es igual a
fx sino igual al negativo de fx esto es
igual al negativo de f de 4 con
solamente este punto podemos ver que
satisface el ser impar porque es igual
al negativo de fx pero vamos a probar
los demás puntos para estar seguros
efe de 1 es igual a 5 a que es igual
efe de menos 1 pues es igual a menos 5
nuevamente efe - x es igual al negativo
de fx x
coincide y efe de 0 es igual a 0
si nos preguntamos a que es igual efe de
menos 0 pues va a ser igual a efe de 0 y
si tomamos el negativo de 0 va a ser
igual a 0 por lo que podemos ver que
esto sigue siendo consistente con ser
impar podemos ver esto como el negativo
de f de menos 0 que va a seguir siendo 0
esto luce bastante bien para hacer una
función impar elegimos esta opción